vor rund 15 millionen jahren entwickelte
homo habilis als erstes lebewesen den
sogenannten abonnierbaren daumen so wie
wir ihn heute kennen also ein den
restlichen fingern gegenübergestellt die
daumen die einen festen griff aber auch
feinste untersuchungen von objekten
ermöglicht er ist maßgeblich ein grund
für die hohe allgemeine intelligenz des
menschen es gibt zahlreiche tiere mit
größeren gehirn aber spezies die ihre
umwelt filigran untersuchen manipulieren
und sogar werkzeuge verwenden können
ziehen stumpf gesagt einen besonderen
vorteil daraus weniger evolution punkte
in zb geschwindigkeit zu stecken und
lieber mehr intelligenz man denkt neben
den menschenaffen auch an die sehr
intelligenten oktopusse mit ihren 18
tage und clevere elefanten mit ihrem
rüssel eine weitere sache die die
entwicklung der menschlichen intelligenz
grundlegend begünstigt hat ist unsere
sprache in der sich menschen zu immer
größeren jagd gruppen zusammentun
konnten und immer sozialer wurden wenn
man mich jetzt also fragt wieso wirst du
im zeitalter von tastatur touchscreen
und spracherkennung überhaupt noch
selbst schreiben könnte ich ihm
entgegenbringen dass die handschrift
eine fusion aus genau diesen beiden
elementaren dingen ist handfertigkeit
und sprache wenn er war jemand fragen
würde was mir das bringt dann kann ich
nur sagen ich finde schöne handschrift
schön und macht tatsächlich spaß sodomie
das klingt schon länger versuche ich
immer mehr handschriftlich mit einem
digitalen stift notizen auf einem
tablett zu erledigen und ich war auch
schon in der schule immer begeistert
wenn ich so einen wunderschönen
gegliederten toll strukturierten mit
farben perfekt geordneten heft antrag
gesehen hat nur um dann in mein eigenes
selbst zu sehen und ist genau anders zu
machen so halbwegs geändert hat sich das
erst als ich die schreibschrift die uns
in der grundschule tatsächlich
aufgezwungen wurde hinter mir gelassen
habe und jetzt schreibe ich mittlerweile
so aber geht da noch mehr frage ich euch
jetzt schon und hat die handschrift
überhaupt noch eine zukunft genau das
finden wir mit diesem experiment heraus
dieses video wird unterstützt von
lettershops sind erstmal möchte ich euch
in einige sonderheit meine schrift ein
weinig habe zwar wie die meisten anderen
auch zuerst dieses jahr gelernt mir dann
aber von meiner schwester carina diese
schreibweise abgeschaut die ihr auch vom
computer kennt eine weitere eigenart ist
dass sich die zahl fünf nicht mitnehmen
als dicker bauch und deckel drauf machen
so wie ihr wahrscheinlich sondern und
ich weiß jetzt für einige von euch echt
grausam das mit anzusehen ich mache es
einfach in einem schwung und ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt immer noch nicht
wirklich was genau der sinn dahinter
dass das so aufzuteilen aber spaß
beiseite
schauen wir uns mal einige beispiele an
von menschen die bereits das erreicht
haben was ich lernen will und die ihr
wissen mit uns teilen möchten also das
sieht aus wie gehen zurück
das ist einfach ich finde es richtig
schön ist das schön wie schön ist das
alles aus leder und so kämpfen premier
praktisch schon ein deal ist genial
meine recherchen ergeben dass es einige
fundamentale regeln gibt die man
befolgen muss um schön zu schreiben
jeder buchstabe soll immer gleich
aussehen in der abstand zwischen zwei
wörtern soll so groß sein wie ein
kleines ende der bauch eines jeden
buchstaben muss geschlossen sein
abstände zwischen zwei buchstaben sollen
eng sein ohne sie zu berühren aber vor
allem regelmäßig ganz grundsätzlich
läuft alles darauf hinaus
regelmäßigkeiten und harmonien
herzustellen in allen bereichen die eine
schrift ausmacht abstand zwischen
buchstaben abstand zwischen wörtern
immer gleiche neigung konsistente tiefe
bei tiefen buchstaben und konsistente
höhe bei hohen buchstaben konsistente
ausrichtung in der senkrechten bei den
grundkörper ihr versteht schon was ich
meine
kümmern wir uns jetzt also erstmal um
die form welche form ist die schönste
ich suche mir also eine stimmige
schriftart aus dem internet die als
alltagstauglich ist am ende entscheide
ich mich aber für die standard
schriftart calibre und erstelle eine
übersicht von jedem buchstaben groß und
klein und auch den zahlen eine übersicht
an der ich später immer wieder
orientieren kann
zum üben erstelle ich eine art
arbeitsblatt jede zeile wird von einem
kräftigen muster buchstaben angeführt
und von zehn weiteren blassen gefolgt
zum nachzeichnen sowie platz für ca 30
weitere freihand buchstaben
[Musik]
also auf die idee buchstaben
auszudrucken und die danach zu zeichnen
welche niemals gekommen
hey mir ist gleich aufgefallen dass das
video eigentlich eine einzige riesige
freiwillige strafarbeit ist ich habe
sogar die schule abgebrochen youtube zu
machen und sich hier
warum naja ok also ich treffe ja noch
nicht so wirklich als wert tatsächlich
besser ok irgendwie sehen meine buch
schreiben genauso wenn ich nicht nach
fahrerlaubnis schwierigste wir jetzt
dafür zu sorgen dass jedes einzelne
möglichst perfekt ist und möglichst
gleich aussieht kann man sich jetzt ein
krampf
[Musik]
aber während er hätten sich jetzt gerade
abrackert und zeigen die perfektion
seiner handschrift stecken sollten wir
uns mal mit der frage beschäftigen ob
sich das überhaupt lohnt hat die
handschrift als solcher überhaupt eine
zukunft erst telefon dann die
schreibmaschine anschließend die
tastatur am computer und spätestens das
moderne smartphone war der letzte
sargnagel für die hand kalender notizen
post das alles ist im geschäftsfeld
schon längst weiter scans digitalisiert
so dass ich ohne probleme nie wieder im
leben selbst schreiben müsste also außer
bei rückständigen ämtern wie immer noch
auf eine physische unterschrift bestehen
die tatsächlich deutlich unsicherer ist
und auch leichter zu fälschen als
digitale äquivalente und selbst das gute
alte autogramm stirbt aus wenn man als
youtuber von zuschauern in der regel
immer an welchen fragen und warum auch
nicht es geht schneller und ist
persönlicher es gibt aber durchaus
gegenbewegungen zum einen natürlich die
szene aus der auch diese videos
hervorgehen aber handschrift kann
durchaus noch moderner als tippen seien
lange zeit waren zwar notizen mit
digitalen buchstaben unschlagbar
effizient einfach deswegen da man sie
immer neu anordnen umfärben und
sämtliche inhalte in einem dokument zum
beispiel mit strg f durchsuchen kann
aber mit handschrifterkennung geht das
mittlerweile fast genauso gut dann kann
tausende handschriftliche notizen in
einer sekunde nach einem stichwort
durchsuchen und apple knapp seine
mittlerweile auch 120 euro für etwas ab
das die handschrift durch moderne
technik wieder salonfähig machen soll
aber vor allem finde ich dass
handschrift einen gewissen charme hat
man hat zu dem was man schreibt auch
einfach einen ganz anderen bezug wenn
man jeden einzelnen buchstaben jede
einzelne form selber machen das spiegelt
sich auch in studien zur merkfähigkeit
beim notizen schreiben wieder aber
zurück zu ihm hier funktioniert der
trick mit dem nachzeichnen eigentlich
wirklich wenn ich nicht gerade von einem
krampf geplagt werde der alle ein bis
zwei reihen auftritt empfinde ich es als
eine sehr bewusste art eine schöne form
zu üben anstatt einen buchstaben zu
schreiben und ihn dann hinterher
subjektiv zu bewerten sieht man hier
genau an welcher ecke man zb über die
stränge geschlagen hat und so fühle ich
stumpf eins nach dem anderen etliche
dieser arbeitsplätze aus einige
buchstaben sind aber auch in dieser
perfekten schriftart nicht so schön wie
ich sie gerne hätte ich glaube man wird
nie eine schriftart im internet finden
die man für sich selbst ideal findet
deswegen orientiere ich mich zwar an der
trainings vorlage meine schönen runden
sonst muss und werde ich aber
beibehalten vor allem aber die
reihenfolge in der ich einzelne
buchstaben schreibe hat sich geändert
pq bdh habe ich davor alle in einem
schwung geschrieben was natürlich
schneller geht aber nicht so schön ist
wie es mit erneutem ansätzen ist
irgendwie erinnert mich das an meine
schreibweise der fünf die ja jeder
andere mit absätzen macht ja trotzdem
dabei niemals anfreunden werde ich mich
jedoch mit dem burnout diese ecke hier
macht wirklich kein spaß kommen wir mal
zu einem kleinen feuer nachher vergleich
mal das training dann effektiv nicht
ganz vor allem sehr entspannend und
einfach schön dem ganzen mal so richtig
viel zeit zu geben ist natürlich immer
die frage ob man sich jetzt wirklich
zeit geben will oder ob man einfach nur
kurz irgendwelche notizen auf streiten
möchte aber ich habe tatsächlich gemerkt
dass die meisten buchstaben deutlich
schöner sind wenn man sich schnell und
schwungvoll malt schreibt langsamer ist
also nicht immer gleich schöner hier
seht ihr jetzt einen
vorher-nachher-vergleich des gesamten
alphabets gerade das amg coupé und das
café nicht super schön immer noch mehr
hässlich finde ich dass ge und auch dass
ich gar nicht tatsächlich halbwegs
schnell schreiben ohne dass ich direkt
mit einer alte muster zurückfallen
mir ist schon ein bisschen klar geworden
dass die leute aus diesem grund videos
wahrscheinlich das ganze schon seitdem
sie in der grundschule waren
perfektionieren und normalsterbliche weg
die in der grundschule anna
wachsmalkreide gelutscht haben da
einfach nicht mithalten können aber ich
glaube das auch okay einige meiner
lehrerin wird auf jeden fall aus den
socken hauen wenn sie überhaupt meine
schrift lesen können wenn ihr euch jetzt
denkt hey ich hätte auch lust
schönzuschreiben dafür aber noch einen
schönen stift oder schreiben braucht
oder so wie ich einmal generell gerne
sachen online bestellt könnt ihr dabei
hat eine menge geld mit cashback sparen
dann kletti shops unserem heutigen
sponsor ihr könnt hier komplett
kostenlos hier über die app oder über
die webseite einen von über 3.000 jobs
auswählen der euch interessiert baumarkt
elektronik klamotten ich hab gerade to
be honest megawatt offenberger also gehe
ich hier auf den lieferdienst klick zum
shop und die app mit der ich nun mal
auch immer bestellt öffnet sich nur dass
sich dieses mal zb 6 prozent der
bestellten sommer als cashback
gutgeschrieben bekommen werde ich mir
auf mein konto oder paypal auszahlen
kann und ihr wisst wie viel ich bestellt
das potenzial ist also riesig letztens
habe ich darüber bei obi werkzeug und
blumentöpfe für ein zukünftiges projekt
gekauft und 11 eur 68 gespart und zwei
lampen mail.de auf neue lampen sogar 21
7 cent diesem monat feiert lettershops
seinen siebten geburtstag dazu gibt es
vom 23
bis 30 mai bis zu siebenfach höheres
cashback also zwanzig dreißig oder
vierzig ersparnis über den coach tommy
unterstrich led- oder über die video
beschreibung bekommt er jetzt schon für
den ersten einkauf dreifaches cashback
meine bürger bestellung habe ich jetzt
also zum beispiel 12 euro geschenkt
bekommen das war es von diesem
experiment das kommt fast jede woche
eigentlich dieser experimente also wenn
ihr das nicht verpassen möchte
abonnieren gern ist kanal und simon
zunächst wieder macht's gut
[Musik]